muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and dawa center to enhance the
norwegian dawah if you donate to this
cause you will ensure allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards
[Music]
i'm here with big g and a plus
yes okay
and here as well big h of course with
you guys where is he
[Laughter]
today we're going to be reacting to a
video which i came across which has many
many views uh about seven million
actually i was surprised i didn't come
across this video or that no one sent it
to me before i think we were all
surprised actually because this video
was quite interesting it is actually
yeah not least because there was
actually a muslim representative
did she represent
exactly this is the question right there
was a muslim woman there who at least
looked like a muslim but did not sound
like one
who was answering these questions and
the way this this program works the
spectrum is that they've asked these
questions and then they would stand
on a spectrum
okay on whether they agree
or to what extent they agree and or
disagree
and so there are there are a few
questions here that were asked i think
which are person into the public
discourse which we want to react to so
let's let's look at the first thing
that i i felt was um
pretty important
i actually don't want kids but if i were
to decide to do that i would want them
to to grow up in that environment where
there's no difference between you two
you don't have like a curfew that she
doesn't have or vice versa so hijab what
do you think about that because that's
something a bit you know i would say
well close to all of our hearts but you
know to see a muslim woman um saying
what she said or moving to where she
moved was it the right move
no i don't i don't think it was the
right move but um we can employ hosni
van here or the
thinking good because at this point in
time you can see that generically i mean
when you're raising boys and girls there
are not that many differences in the way
that you're going to raise both of them
in fact there are many rules in islam
which indicate that you should be equal
in gifts
and time spent and your love that you
have for both boys and girls so
generically i mean
uh i don't think it's wrong however
there are obviously differences
especially as boys and girls become
closer to puberty
and become closer to adulthood so
that's what i would say like for for
instance
a boy now who's becoming a man has to
start thinking about protection the
protective role that they would have
this is something we believe in we
believe that for example a boy a son and
a daughter
knowing that the son has advantages
which are anatomical in nature
clearly you would you would guide the
sun to be protective of over the
daughter in a way that you wouldn't tell
the daughter to be protective over the
sun i don't know how to accent do you
agree with uh with that no exactly even
biologically that follows you know i've
had a discussion with feminists in the
park as well you know it's it's it's sad
you know for them to deny their own
biology you know and we're not talking
about exceptions they'll come and say oh
but if there's a woman that's a
kickboxer we're not talking about that
you know it's it's the duty of the male
and like allah says men are the
maintainers and practices of women
period if the one who created me said
that there's there's nothing else that
needs to be loved that's what i was
saying without delving in too much
yeah i was gonna say that if if i was to
push back and play devil's advocate i
would say okay but here we're talking
about kids
should you not be bringing them all up
as protectors should they not all be
exposed to that no what's the definition
protected
look firstly if i have a daughter and
have a son i'll both tell them both how
to protect myself and i'm sure even your
could you send them to bjj you know so
even though you're
against this but in your life you
practice like you take your daughter and
your son to bjj however let's be real
here that when they grow up yeah that we
need to be real with them and tell them
you know and i'm sure they would realize
that with their own biology they'll
understand that a man is tend to be more
stronger and their brother is there to
protect you
why should we be afraid of that that's
why i would say that and you know on
this point you know i take my child to i
would do we do everything with like in
terms of self defense my two i've got
two daughters as you know but the thing
is
i do that now when she's very young and
prepubescent and the same thing with my
son but the moment puberty kicks in i
mean people don't realize the effect of
testosterone when testosterone comes
into the picture i mean it's changing it
actually increases muscle mass by up to
fifty percent
fifty five zero percent
so now you know this is very interesting
you see children right when they grow
older and you see how like for example
girls versus boys before the pubescent
stage girls can sometimes really
dominate boys because they don't there's
no like testosterone advantage and these
kind of things you see that very it's
very often um very common but then when
when pbe hits that's no longer a
question i remember i remember going to
a boxing club when i was younger i want
to mention the club but one of the top
female boxers in the uk actually who
represented gb in
the olympics okay
when i think the first year they had
female boxing yeah
she was basically sparring she was a
woman she was part of the 14 year old
boys
13 14 year olds yeah eights and your
nines she would be inconceivable to put
her in with you know a 21 year old or
something like that
who's her weight or equal weight because
the advantages are so well described
then everyone knows in in that industry
that it would be so disadvantageous for
them okay should we move on to the next
one because i think here we're assuming
the best
oh here we go hi guys
second that i agree with that statement
but i feel like the heavy restrictions
that are placed on it by our government
just dictating what we can do with our
bodies is really infuriating and then
seeing people who have kids and resent
it for the rest of their lives and
raising children that they never wanted
it's frustrating and so do you think
that those parents that are struggling
with raising their children that they
didn't have the option for adoption or
other ways it depends like for a lot of
cultures adoption is not okay so as you
guys saw she was strongly agreeing with
abortion but we know this just to make
this clear
that according to the the schools of
thought in islamic jurisprudence three
out of four schools say
that after 120 days i mean up to 120
days you can abort
in certain circumstances not not all
circumstances and one school of thought
says 40 days
it's inconceivable to think that after
120 days that a muslim
can believe in something referred to as
late stage terminal abortion
which is as you know in in america in
different parts of the western world and
different parts of the world can go up
to six months which if you've ever seen
a child a child can survive in six
months the way they take and we couldn't
even put this like as a picture of you
know a video how they actually extract
and cut up a baby that's five months old
literally a viable child a viable when i
say viable i'm talking about living it
has a pulse it has a heart it has organs
it has a brain it can
it can
it has a nervous system you killed this
child practically
you're saying that a woman should have
the right to do this
on what grounds do you think this is
commensurate with the islamic teaching
to be honest i believe this it's it's
just based on nothing no rationale no
logic it's just basically
i see an insecure muslim woman yeah
who's dominated uh yes you know with
ideologically yeah in the west yes and
she's just basically
like she's just saying you know i'm here
do wherever you like me and wherever you
go i'm to follow you that's what i see
because there is no way if i sat that
sister down i said do you genuinely
believe this she would say to me
i hope she would say to me no like i
don't even know if i can say that she
will say no and i hope she will say no
but the thing is here how could you can
you imagine this sister she's going to
watch this i don't know if you have kids
imagine you have a child and i want you
to look at that child after you after
you look at that child i want you to
look at that child and say you know what
your sibling
imagine bro
they were ripped piece by piece piece by
piece because we need to put this into
perspective when you come in and say oh
that's wrong no no look at your child
and say and if you did ever do abortion
may allah forgive you and repent look at
your child and say one of your siblings
that died
or killed not died killed and bit by lib
limb by limb and we ripped them into
pieces
you're not talking about early abortion
yeah
no we're talking about five months yes
but she's she's saying totally agree
about her and the question is very clear
so yes so
limb by limb you've literally killed
your own child you've killed your own
child so you should
bring up the child and say this is what
i did to your sibling would you do that
the quran states that when the child
that the female interestingly
female infanticide that the quran is
against when the female child
says for what for what sin did i what
did you kill me for yes yes
[Music]
what did you kill me for feminism
exactly no no no no no what did you kill
me can you watch under the judgement
what did you kill me for uh for uh an
ideology because i was insecure
i think what's interesting here is the
the slogan they use is my body my choice
but absolutely your body it's not your
body
it's my body one bro one brother made a
very good choice
not choice he made a very good point and
he said
that puts the whole kind of impetus on
the past person themselves but they're
not the only one that's responsible or
affected by that decision exactly that's
right what about the choice of the
father what about the choice of the
grandfather about the choice of the
family these sorts of things it's like
you mentioned about human rights it's
all about
what you owed and not what you owe and
that's one of the issues that we have
with this that's point number one point
number two even
ronaldo himself he was one of the
children and he mentions this in his
documentary that he was supposed to be
aborted he was supposed to be gone but
if we didn't have ronaldo then we
wouldn't have such a a
a football star that people look up to
because he doesn't have tattoos he
doesn't drink alcohol you know he looks
after his family and and somebody that
is i'm not saying the best of role
models but i'm saying he's better than
most
so these two things i think uh
are very important things to reflect
about but you you wanted to say
something about my body and my choice i
forget this is my body my choice no so
we we are created by allah and we belong
to allah simple as that yeah this again
it's it's a matter of akida bro and
having tawakon and allah because when
you're aborting this child again it's a
lack of
because if your thinking is i can't look
after them okay allah says in the quran
he is the one that provides one life all
these issues linked to tawheed and his
mainly
not trusting having trust in allah
knowing that he's the creator that
created the heavens and the earth that
he can provide for you it's not deep
well
it's an insulin can you imagine the one
who created the heavens do you believe
in him yeah i do but do you believe it
can provide for you uh what an insult
what's an insult there's there's also
another thing that needs to be
understood here they might say you know
what she's just um she's just a woman
you know leave her alone
the thing is there's two types of
muslims that can go on a show like that
one without hijab that people will
assume certain things let's face it we
do live in a society where we judge by
what's apparent whether it's right right
or whether it's wrong if somebody sees a
hijabi woman on there and they're not
that exposed to islam they will assume
that that is the orthodox opinion of
islam so you're saying that there is a
cut of age and you're saying three
months now you could argue maybe she
knew that maybe she didn't know that
four months but with all due respect
like if she didn't know that and she
knows she's the only hijabi on that show
it's a big channel she has a
responsibility to say and represent her
religion because she's wearing the
attire if you're wearing the attire of a
policewoman and then somebody asks you
law and you get the law wrong you can't
say hey don't judge me by the way i look
so she's she is responsible and she does
need to be sensible about these things
even if you make the argument that maybe
it was cut out maybe this may be that
she should you know ensure that her
religion is represented well i think
with her the thing is what is most
despicable
about her
kind of
portrayal of islam or lack thereof
actually to be honest with you is the
fact that she's being so inconsistent
with her worldview
look she's representing islam through
her attire like you've mentioned
and she's meant to represent a muslim
voice on the show yeah she all she's
doing is spouting left-wing propaganda
second word feminism
this is not a representation of what
muslims believe and she's not
self-consistent with islam she's trying
to bring two opposing ideologies
together second wave feminism and islam
and it's just looking wrong first of all
i want to i want to show one thing okay
they asked a question which is
that do they believe that the world
would be a better place if it's run by
women yeah
and look where she stands on the on
there she doesn't have a strong stance
but look where she stands as well but
then look at the contribution i want to
focus on the contribution of the white
feminists white feminists because i
actually think it was a very good
contribution from within her own
paradigm
how is that any different than saying i
believe that the world would be better
if it were run by men like if we're
going to say that on this token we get
that on that token that's not even
balanced at all now if you compare that
with the muslims contribution okay
let's see what the muslim has to say and
then and then comment on all of it
that's why i chose this one too because
i don't think it should be one or the
other i definitely think that
when it's only man run they're missing
the rest of society you can't really
operate the world or any government or
leadership if you're not embracing the
second half of society so
for me looking at the white feminist
she to be honest is way more
self-consistent with her ideology than
the muslim who's attempting to be a
feminist who really is uh who's
sacrificing her religion is
contradictory in her stances because
this woman at least she's
self-consistent she realizes that
actually if feminism is an egalitarian
discourse especially if it's liberal
feminism
then it shouldn't ensure that people
have freedom of choice
and and she and also freedom and equal
opportunities and she starts to realize
okay this is how it should play out if
we are to be self-consistent the muslim
she has no care to try and represent uh
consistency or be consistent in any way
so she's just saying yeah it would
actually be better if it's run by women
but the problem is of course that islam
gives rights to men that it doesn't give
to women it gives responsibilities as
well to men that it does not give to
women
um
not least of course the fact that the
man is meant to be the manager of the
household
that men are is and protectors of women
but because of what he gave one over the
other
and the word
which is obedience you know for men to
women women to men in the in the
household is not something which is just
relegated to the hadith literature it's
actually in 434 itself
in the quran itself
if they obey you meaning this is the
normative state
the point is
if you're saying that the world will be
better run by women what is your stance
on men being leaders of every household
because
men being lead on an aggregate level
this would mean
that what you want is an inverse of
what's going on which is completely
anti-islamic what do you guys think i
think the
an interesting parallel you can draw is
with regards to approximately 124 000
prophets that have come and all of them
being male and leaders leaders of the
religion exactly imams the leaders of uh
every single congregational prayer
that's valid within the paradigm of
islam being a male figure what would be
your answer with regards to that so it
does seem contradictory to an islamic
point of view i think she could have
worded it better well alan if she
actually meant this
but it doesn't seem like she's somebody
that is
committed but i mean representative of
orthodox islam of course not the thing
is
to be quite honest with you she's sold
her soul to the left-wing ideologies and
for all intents and purposes this could
lead to major coffer
that takes someone out of the fold of
islam and we have to just call the spare
the spirit i'm not calling her kafer
although what she's what she's
representing is kofor akbar a major
coffee and most of the positions of the
implied intelligence of her position
what we need to realize is that these
positions are unacceptable islamically
that's as simple as really as simple as
that these positions are unacceptable
islamically you need to realize that
this is another it's another way of life
it's another ideology you can call it if
you like another religion yes second
word feminism is like another religion
that has different presuppositions
different assumptions different
hierarchies different priorities you
cannot maintain an islamic committed
islamic
point of view and this at the same time
you will be cognitively dissonant which
is a psychological disorder or you'll be
a liar to yourself and to others around
you or you'll be a clandestine apostate
someone who doesn't actually have money
someone who doesn't actually believe in
islam
but just pretends to be muslim for
social and cultural
reasons
and may allah protect us and our people
from this because at the end of the day
we're seeing more and more of these
kinds of figures come up and they're
trying to normalize it but there is no
space for that in the islamic
environment at all
would you agree yeah of course you know
we're happy with our religion you know
we're pleased with our lord you know
it's as simple as that man let's just
get away with this insecurities you know
at the end of the day it's as simple as
that but that's why that's where it
stems from we don't understand a lack of
tolhee not knowing your religion it's
true and the weapons is then you become
like a is it a leaf that you know
wherever the wind blows you you know
you're you're wherever where feminism oh
i'm a feminist that's what it boils down
to guys you know and that's where the
root of the problem is be proud be happy
you know if you see a one phenomena is
islam has all these regulations and laws
and stuff in place which is totally
opposing to the liberal view but
thousands of people come to islam
because the thing is when you're true to
yourself like if i you know once i i
spent three years looking into different
religions bro once i established islam
as the truth i knew i knew my dad my
family my society is going to shun me
yeah bro if i had if i the last thing i
should have done was accept islam the
last thing i should done but it's the
truth bro i can't lie to myself and if
it's the truth i have to stand by it and
when i say i i i this is from allah i'm
not saying i do something personal it's
with allah's guidance but what i'm
saying is man be
proud of your religion man is it damn
hard you're there trying to be an
advocate for feminism and they're
rejecting him and they're throwing you
that woman came and just you know
dismissed you you know be firm with your
religion have tawakkul and allah trust
in allah build that connection with him
you don't need feminism and all the
schisms that's what i would say
absolutely bro anything you want to say
is your channel that well
[Music]
[Laughter]
just one small thought comes to mind
which is what a scholar said that back
in the days we had masjids
the mosques
that were unbaked they were made from
unbaked clay
yeah but the people that emerged from
them was gonna be a good one take a step
back
they were baked but today the masjids
are baked but the people that emerge
from the masjids are unbaked
so i mean we although we we have stepped
up we
although we have
like
billions 1.8 billion muslims
but
if we only had 313 with the caliber of
badr today we would be on a different
plane exactly so we need to take a leaf
from these muslims read the seerah the
history and and and go and take the
positives from that time and one of the
positives that we've highlighted is
being confident in your religion and
number two having knowledge of your
religion and
becoming people of substance and people
of action exactly and what you said
there for example that there's a hadith
of the process which mentions this that
on that day or the process tell them
companies you're going to be vast in
number you know and um
you're going to be like rubbish yes but
it's going to be like the form of the
siege yeah and that and why it's very
interesting because ends there he
actually says and he says why he says
because
yes it will put the love of the dunya
and fear of death and that's exactly why
would someone fear of death we all did i
should and help um told the process i'm
scared of death it's not about that it's
not that you don't want to meet allah
it's that you're attached to the dunya
you don't want to die because you're
like no i want to stay here aki if you
know allah promised you something better
we all scared of death but to at least
be firm and be like you know
it is going to be happy but you've
attached yourself to the dunya so much
and you know what it might it might have
been death in those days but nowadays it
might be death socially you're afraid of
of dying socially
your soul your
and it will come back to being strange
and he said
so glad tidings to the strangers
and this is insha allah
muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and dawa center to enhance the
norwegian tawa if you donate to the
scores you will ensure allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra reward